es un problema que argentina lleva
arrastrando desde hace décadas a la
deuda externa y si bien las causas son
diversas los analistas señalan la
importancia de un actor en concreto eeuu
y sus políticas regionales la trampa de
la deuda a la que están sometidas desde
hace década de los países
latinoamericanos tienen como principal
responsable a los eeuu los mecanismos
financieros y de endeudamiento para
mantener sometidos a los gobiernos de
nuestros países a llevar adelante
políticas que beneficien los negocios de
las empresas estadounidenses con la
crisis económica de finales de los 70
argentina pidió préstamos a acreedores
internacionales
especialmente a bancos estadounidenses
también conocidos como fondos buitres y
aunque el tipo de interés era casi nulo
al principio eeuu endureció sus
políticas monetarias con el tiempo algo
que hizo la deuda insostenible evaluó la
moneda nacional y aumentó su dependencia
estamos absolutamente decididos
cumplir con nuestras obligaciones
y a pagar la deuda pero para poder pagar
la deuda tenemos que trabajar y mucho
tras años de lucha la deuda ha ido
subiendo cada vez más recientemente la
pandemia de kobe 19 aumentó los tipos de
interés agravando la crisis económica en
la región y obligando a argentina a usar
sus nuevos préstamos para pagar las
deudas anteriores el objetivo primario
de todos unidos no es que argentina
solucione sus problemas sino más bien
una cuestión geopolítica y por otro lado
el poder mantener cierto control que
tiene históricamente eeuu sobre
latinoamérica un tema por el que los
argentinos llevan manifestándose desde
los 80 defienden que su bienestar es más
importante que pagar una deuda